hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the match Ramesh Babu pregnant
under vs. Westley so that was played in
the Leone Masters 2018 you already seen
game number one
Prabhu got that very nice victory with
the black pieces here Prague has the
white pieces and I think you'll be very
impressed by by how this game went and
there there is this one moment of
complete double blindness that well it
could only be explained due to it being
a rapid game and due to Wesley so being
the number two player regarding rating
in the world
so prog well of course it wasn't even
hoping to I mean to find themselves in
such a situation we're going to talk
about that some more but before that a
photo challenge a simple one here it is
best of luck to everyone who is the
gentleman here I will give you a little
hint he is the creator of the original
immortal game so best of luck to
everyone and I do have a photo of this
matchup I didn't show it in the previous
video but here they are Wesley and
Prague oh really really smooth looking
tuxedos there so I hope you enjoyed that
let's check out the game Prague has the
white pieces in this game and he opens
with E 4 we have C 5 by Wesley the
Sicilian defense yeah I still have to
get used to it since my vacation c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6 now and
Bishop to b5 check the canal attack
Knight to d7 and now a four-night to
have sex by Wesley Knight to c3 and g6
Wesley doesn't go for the immediate a
sex he you know keeps everything open
and wants to create something original
we have a 5 cents Wesley missed his
opportunity to play a six now probably
grab some more space on the Queen side
we have a six now Bishop to c4 and here
Bishop to g7 but the g7 is actually a
terrible blunder by Wesley that
basically allows Prague to win the game
immediately here well yeah I mean I
don't even want you to pause the video
because I'm sure you can all see it you
can all see the standard ideas g6 has
been played by yourself
has been played nice the d7 has been
played and now the knight is blocking
the light square bishop so of course all
of you do realize that Bishop captures
on f7 would win the game here
immediately
because after King captures Knight g5
check and the King has three options
King yet King f8 and King g8 of course
King gate loses immediately 296 the
queen has nowhere to go this is covered
by the night this is covered by the pawn
and there is a pawn on e5 so the Queen
can't come to a5 so here whatever black
plays next move Knight captures Queen on
the 8th it's game over
on the other hand after King captures on
f7 and 95 check you could also go King
f8 but then 96 comes with check and you
lose the Queen immediately so what the
only option you have left is team g8 and
then you get 96 attacking the Queen the
only place Square available for the
Queen is EA so Queen to it and now comes
a knight to c7 again attacking the Queen
and the rook once you move the Queen
let's say Queen d8 knife captures here
and white is already up the exchange and
there's no threat of this Knight ever
being captured because the pawn is
already here on a5 so next move Knight
b6 is coming and it's it's an easy game
for white so the only possible reason I
could you know think of for for Prager
not playing Bishop capture sons and f7
is because he's playing go against
Wesley so he you know he if he can't
even imagine that Wesley would make such
a mistake and so here in this position
Prager played d3 simply continuing the
game you know like Wesley didn't blunder
the game away and okay Wesley castles
and now the opportunity has passed
Prabhu castles we have Knights to be 8
preparing to remain over tonight but
this loss probably to immediately take
advantage as the knight is no longer
guarding e5 so Prager pushes a
five-night back to e8
now this game Wesley here plays two
moves with the knight back nice to d5
and now comes the knight to c6 Knight to
b6 a very nice word for the night rook
to b8 and here one of my think okay I'm
gonna just
leave my night on me six it's a very
nice square but Prague has a different
idea he plays Knight captures on see it
immediately rook captures and now II 6
forcing Wesley to play f6 and although
it's it's a it's a really ugly looking
move blacks really not doing all that
bad here what's this plan will be to
somehow bring the Queen over to push d5
bring bring the Queen over to d6 and
then we are Knight the c7 attack this
week pawn with the Queen and the night
so Queen to e1 by Prague we have d5 now
attacking the bishop bishop moves to b3
and now Queen to d6 next his plan is
night to c7 and winning the e6 pawn rook
to a for a very nice idea by Prague ooh
we have night to c7 and now comes a
bishop to f4 attacking the Queen and now
you see the real idea of rook to e4 now
if Wesley decides to play Queen captures
here with the idea of exchanging Queens
and grabbing a pawn he would lose the
game immediately because Queen captures
Knight captures and Bishop captures on
d5 pinning the e6 Knight only way to
defend that the king of 7 but now comes
Luke II for the whole point of rook to
a4 move knight defense night and now
comes rocky 1 and now there is no more
pieces there are no more pieces that can
defend the knife so you have to give up
the exchange here and after captures
captures Bishop c7 attacking the knight
here it's it's easily winning in for
white so Wesley doesn't go for it Wesley
first blocks with Knight to e5 we have
got captures pawn captures and here c4
and here was the place a very nice move
efore upon sacrifice after D characters
he plays d4 creates a past a nice past D
pawn and completely locks out this
bishop and rook from the game for now
'if I've attacking the Queen and Queen
to c6 now grabbing the pawn is possible
but then you allow the progress Queen to
become active we are this very nice
efore square coming into the game with
tempo so instead after a 5 Queen to c6
keeping around rockin a 4 also not
allowing Queen to e4 and well you you
have to keep this Bishop here now
guarding this rope so
decides to move it back hopefully he
will be able to transfer this rope into
the attack may be a rogue g3 or rogue to
h3 in the future we have night captures
and e6 and now Bishop to a for attacking
the Queen Queen to c7 and now rook to b3
we have nice to d8
preparing Truman over tonight but also
from d8 the knight will be guarding the
b7 pawn so Queen to b4 will not be so
terrible Queen to e4 and now buying that
b7 pawn and now comes Queen captures on
a5 West grabs the pawn Bishop to d7
we have rook to b8 and now comes Queen
to d5 with check King to h8 and now
comes Knight to g5 and all of a sudden
for the price of this one pawn it seems
that Prague has a very nice attack here
the queen is controlling the g8 square
the knight is a very nicely placed on g5
attacking h7 rook to h3 is coming so a
lot of things could happen here we have
Queen to c7 by Wesley and here f4 by
pragma and reinforcing that e5 pawn
it's interesting but the immediate
Knight captures on h7 unfortunately
doesn't work for white because after
King captures rook to h3 check Bishop to
h6 and there is a really no good way to
continue this attack whatever whatever
white tries black will be able to defend
so here first Prague plays f4
reinforcing d5 pawn so maybe later
this will be an idea maybe sacrificing
the knight rock h3 maybe giving up the
rook as well and then maybe bringing
another rock into the game via a nice
rook lift so b5 we have rook to h3 now
attacking the h7 pawn and here h6 and
here the knight cannot be captured so
here first Prague should you know take a
more take a moment here play captures
captures and only after the his pawn
structure here has been improved then
decided what to play however he will
move the night Stewie forward whether he
will move simply the bishop or what not
but here he played Knights to e6 he
allows this exchange so Wesley is very
happy to exchange knights as his knight
is a pretty terrible piece his his rocks
aren't connected so here we have Knight
captures Bishop captures and rook to b6
now
attacking progress Bishop here and here
again you wanna take a moment
maybe capture here prepare for pawn
capture some beef I've moved the Bishop
to g4 and then you know figure out what
to do what to do next but here Prager
played rook to g3 he prepared a nice
attack against this g6 pawn but here he
completely missed Wesley's idea so feel
free to pause the video here and find
the move that promised that wins Wesley
the game so I will give it a couple of
seconds for you to figure out if you
would like to do it for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
know you are an excellent player and for
those of you who want to enjoy the show
the move program is was rook to d8
simply attacking the Queen as Queen is
the only piece that is defending the
bishop on e6 you really have no options
here we have to move the Queen and then
ro captures on e6 basically wins the
Queen for black and there are no tricks
here for example rook captures will
capture screen captures there's really
nothing to do here black will simply
pull the pawn and you don't have time
for a rock lift as d to bay immediately
wins the game so yeah after this rook to
d8 move there was really nothing to do
here and Prague was forced to resign the
game so yeah this was game number two
from their match and with such such a
nice start after game number one you
know it's it's amazing that here after
only seven moves have been played here
Bishop to g7 by West the sole problem is
this Bishop captures an f7 idea and also
he missed the opportunity to take this
match with a 2 to 2 0 lead and then it's
questionable if Wesley could win two
games in a row but he didn't he lost
this game and then the game number 3 was
drawn and then Wesley was able to win
game 4 and thus win the match two and a
half to one and a half so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank large to Sundquist
a mark gammy and the M Jeremy Fisher for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous
here I think all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video and one bonus info
Instagram has just unleashed its
Instagram TV so it's something new so
I'm I'm gonna create some content for
that platform as well as now you can
have a channel and Instagram as well so
if any of you are interested in some
extra content feel free to follow my
Instagram account my Instagram channel
and hopefully you're gonna enjoy that
content as well see you soon